San Francisco could soon become the
first city to block the sale of
e-cigarettes all in an effort to
crackdown on vaping by kids
city leaders voted unanimously yesterday
to ban the sale of the products in city
limits the measure does still require
final approval and there'll be another
vote and a Warner is here she's been
following the story for a long time and
why this city leaders want a full ban on
e-cigarettes sales
well Tony supporters of the measure want
the FDA to review the effects of
e-cigarettes on public health before the
product goes on sale they hope that by
banning e-cigarette sales it will limit
young people's access to them something
they call teen vaping is an epidemic
think of the health costs and think of
what's going to happen to our youth it
is unacceptable one by one the San
Francisco supervisors spoke at City Hall
Tuesday I am gravely concerned with the
skyrocketing use of vaping products by
youth it is as easy as clicking purchase
online
there is no verification companies like
Joule have had three years to submit
their product and marketing to the FDA
the question is why haven't they San
Francisco City Attorney Dennis Herrera
co-sponsored and drafted the legislation
he says cities and states are taking
action because the FDA has not the FDA
has totally abdicated its responsibility
to do the review that they should have
done it the FDA says e cigarette
manufacturers must get their products
approved by 2022 yet the products are
already for sale and middle school
students use increased by more than 40
percent from 2017 to 2018 San Francisco
is just one of many cities taking action
the campaign for tobacco-free kids notes
that nearly 30 cities have banned
menthol cigarettes and flavored tobacco
products and their sales Matthew Myers
heads the group what we're already
seeing nationwide is real momentum to
rein in the cigarette industry
particularly the flavors that have
fueled the epidemic among kids most of
the e-cigarette market share is held by
jewel labs the company is fighting back
by proposing a ballot initiative in San
Francisco that it says would tighten you
access to tobacco products but preserve
access for adults if passed it would
stop any ban from going into effect over
a year ago jewelle administrator ashley
gould told us the company had changed
its marketing approach and did not mean
to attract teens I will take that
criticism but we know now we're working
very hard and we are committed Jule
also is the largest donor of the group
Coalition for reasonable vaping
regulation which said a ban would open
the floodgates to a black market while
leaving cigarettes the leading
preventable cause of death on the
shelves the Coalition has enlisted the
help of community organizers like San
Francisco Reverend Floyd Trammell who
disagrees with the band but persons who
are of 21 I think they should have the
choice to choose what they want to do
jewelle lab said in a statement it will
continue to work to enact stronger
regulation and enforcement rather than
complete prohibition the FDA won't
comment on pending legislation but says
it's committed to tackling the troubling
epidemic of e-cigarette use among kids
so what are the next steps Anna so there
has to be a second vote on this then the
mayor presumably who's been supportive
would probably sign this and then it
would take about six to seven months to
take effect a Herrera says look they
could by then actually get approval from
the FDA in his opinion so it might have
no impact at all but he's basically
saying that because the FDA and their
opinion is dragging its feet in the view
of her or another you know city and
state officials that cities and states
need to step up and do something about
it now but what's peculiar is while
they're trying to ban e-cigarettes which
the American Cancer Society says is
markedly less harmful than a traditional
cigarette traditional cigarettes are
still everywhere why not target them I
think the problem is that the teen
vaping has become an epidemic and the
the rules that they have to keep teens
away clearly are not working and the
question is what do you do about that
and San Francisco is saying this is what
we're gonna do if you ban it for adults
too though it takes a potential tool to
help them quit off the market if you
make it completely unavailable which at
this point clearly it's and there are
still a lot of questions about the
effects of cigarettes we'll be talking
about this yes all right
thank you very much thank you